moroto welcome along to this um meeting
uh which is a hearing for the gambling
policies for the inval city council uh
we have an apology from councelor Leslie
SOA um like to move that's accepted I
doish seconded yes thanks R put that all
in favor against
carried
um we'll start off with uh an an
overview of the um proposed policy then
go through the uh people who've um come
to present or zoom in uh it is my
intention that we will deliberate and
open um I can see no reason for us to go
into public excluded bearing in mind the
public interest and there are actually
no matters of privacy that need to be
considered but first if we could get an
overview of the uh why we're here today
ran and Darren welcome
along k Mr chair and counselors we have
consulted on the prepose board tab
gamling tab venues policy and the
proposed class for gamling venues policy
from September 18 to October 18
2023 this is an opportunity for the
hearings panel to consider submissions
and hear from some
11 submissions were received and six
supported Capp policies for
implementation and five supported
syncing L policies for implementation it
is also important to note of the
pre-engagement H with stakeholders that
happened prior to consultation which
supported us which supported syncing L
policies for
implementation the gaming machine
Association of New Zealand Hospitality
New Zealand the lion foundation tatura
and the problem gamp Foundation
requested to speak to their
submissions the gaming machine
Association Hospitality New Zealand and
the lion Foundation recommended capped
policies for
implementation specific recommendations
to expand the relocation provision of
the Capp of the draft Capp policies were
recommended that were placed for
consultation the problem gamling
foundation and tatura recommended gold
standard syncing L without the
relocation trans and merger provision
Provisions for implementation defat
recommended amending appendix two of the
draft policies to add clearer CBD and
business to Zone
boundaries majority of the submissions
uh supported council's initiative to
introduce a voluntary code of contact
the problem gamling Foundation
recommended Council to consider
supporting actions to reaffirm the
intent of the voluntary code of conduct
Hospitality New Zealand recommended
adding to the code of conduct to inform
the creation of
phenopen when gamling uh license
operators allow intoxicated patrons to
remain on the gamling premises and I
would like to take this opportunity to
apologize to Mr jro his name was
misspelled in the
report thank you any questions at this
point
everybody's had a chance to uh gosh
that's a sve photo isn't it everybody's
had a chance to read through um policy
and what's proposed in the
submissions
excellent uh if there are no further
questions thank you very much
Laura welcome along uh as you know Laura
um we generally allocate around about 10
minutes how you want to use that time is
up to you but if you'd like to allow us
to ask questions a little bit of
allowance for that at the other end
would be be useful thank you for taking
the time to submit on behalf
of uh the time is
yours pop took my name is Laura Pope and
I'm a health promotion advisor for the
National Public Health Service as a part
of tat order gambling is a social
economic and health issue that affects
us all harm is met by the individual the
far now and the broader Community
gambling is not an isolated addiction
but rather po has a potential negative
impacts on the totality of the
individual's health and wellbeing the
impact of gambling is so severe it can
cause uh negative effects on health both
morbidity and mortality cause emotional
distress create financial difficulties
reduce the performance of an individual
cause relationship breakdown and result
in criminal activity or neglect of
personal responsibility I ities
according to the Ministry of Health
about one five people in New Zealand
will experience harm in their lifetime
due to their own or someone else's
gambling factors that cause people to
gamble include accessibility Leisure
social connectivity stress impulsivity
and other mental health illnesses in New
Zealand moldi and Pacific people are
disproportionately represented when
considering gambling harm and addiction
moldy have been found to be over 3.13
times as likely to exhibit severe to
moderate gambling addictions followed by
Pacific people that were 2.56 times as
likely in public health it is important
that we consider what is Equitable for
populations such as moldi and Pacific
because the health outcomes are so much
more severe than
pakha therefore the best approach to
take with policy is one that will help
to achieve p or good well-being for
populations that are
disadvantaged a contributing factor to
gambling harm outcomes is accessibility
to venues of the current gambling venues
in enago 14 out of 15 of them are
located in medium to high levels of
deprivation it is more likely that
residents that live within those areas
will engage with gambling this is a this
as a result increases the burden for
those that are already living in high
deprivation
in inago the total money lost to
gambling over the past 5 years has
substantially increased last year the
amount spent hit a record high with 17
million lost to gambling at the pokeys
of the money lost to gambling only 5.5
million has been donated to the
community which sits under the required
40% of the money that is given to the
community the majority is given to to
support in fact last year year that was
2.2 million of the 5.5 million which is
almost half of which was given the
National Public Health Service is in
support of the sinking lid policy for
both Tab and class 4 gambling an article
on cing gambling in New Zealand the
effectiveness of local government policy
intervention has found that the sinking
lid policy is the most effective when
preventing gambling harm in altero in
New Zealand absolute Caps or the gold
standard approach that we recommend have
estimated to reduce the number of
electronic gaming machines by 15% and
venues by 16% per 100,000 population
over a period of a year a decrease in
gambling intervention services can be
found within a year of a sinking lid
policy implementation which indicates
there is a reduction in harmful gambling
we propose a gold standard sinking lid
which prevents the movement of class 4
and TB venue license
and prevents the movement of electronic
gaming machines this is the best public
health approach to prevent and minimize
harm from gambling one of the
nervousness around creating a sinking
lid policy is that it will force people
to go online Co 19 lockdown was able to
provide us with insight into behavior
when the gambling and tab venues closed
down during that period there was no
evidence to show that the proportionate
amount of people that use gambling
venues went online while they were
closed in fact the trend saw that as
soon as venues opened there was a
significant Spike and gambling use and
that year was more profitable than the
last as a fundamental document for the
for ala on New Zealand it is important
that we consider t or wangi and the
obligations that we each have to uphold
and honor it we must look to contribute
to Equitable outcomes for Mal and it is
necessary that as a local Authority you
aim to address inequity and eliminate
disparities therefore we urge Council to
consider what policy is best for moldy
health and well-being
outcomes as a service we are pleased to
see that the council are considering
adopting the best practice code of
conduct we feel that this will help to
solidify and reinforce the policies the
and guidelines that come from the
Department of internal affairs and
remove any room for uncertainty
thank you for taking the time to listen
to me today I hope that you'll consider
our feedback in your decision making
nor K thank you Laura um thank you for
your presentation I have a few questions
I wouldn't mind um just getting a
response to before I go to the other
counselors you use the term lost to
gambling so is there a term one from
gambling that's used in the measurement
as
well so what do you mean by that well
it's what I'm trying to figure out what
you mean oh um well I guess it's it's
saying that um there was $17
million spent at
gambling from that how muches comes we
say that that's lost to gambling because
the person that has spent that money has
lost that money there an
assumption um yeah I I think it's
statistically I accept that the majority
would be invested lost whatever but I'm
I'm not sure about using that as a as a
full
measurement with um the
figures that you used for the amount
that's returned to the community MH uh
you said it was below the requirement is
that across all agencies yes it was on
the there's a website so and by all
agency I mean that's a cumulative figure
rather than all agencies are below that
yeah it's not accounting for each
individual agencies it's as a total and
amongst those agencies are there some
who go above that minimum requirement I
didn't look into that
um you mentioned that sying lid policies
um have been shown
to uh bring a reduction in uh gambling
numbers so with that in mind bearing in
taking into account that the last
period of the policy has been the only
time that we have been CA has there been
a change in the figures so we're a
gambling harm figures reducing during
all the previous years and they've just
gone up
recently so the study that I mentioned
um looked at um different policies and
how they affected different populations
so I so again it's a cumulative response
rather than are there any figures that
you have that talk about the this area
Caro um not necessarily because it's
it's very hard to measure and get a
study done in a place like inago like
you'd have to have the resourcing and
things like that to provide that
information can you tell me where the
figures for online gambling came from
and how they measured it was released
from the Department of internal affairs
they just noted that there was um
nothing to say that as many people that
were in the Pokey venues or tab class 4
tab being used went online um there was
an increase I think um the Ministry of
Health released um some information
about um different statistics on um
online gambling use I think they did a
survey across um the population and they
did find that people um and increase the
use in my lotto um but as I said it it
wasn't proportionate so so it's it's a
user survey or survey of users as
opposed to a specific measurement okay
thank you that's useful thanks
Laura you've got you've covered my two
thank you um thank you Laura thank you
for your submission and your very
detailed um delivery this morning
through your submission I know that um
Tata Ora has mentioned that
uh T should not be permitted within a
100 meter of sensitive premises to an
ATM do you have stats on TB that are to
within that um area that they are on the
up use of money specifically used for
gambling I don't know that I have stats
but I um it it is something that we
advis because that I mean it would be an
assumption to say that people are more
likely to go
and use the money machine if it's right
there it's at your convenience um I
think it was just about um making some
consistency across the two policies CU I
noted that in the class four venues you
had listed sensitive premises whereas in
the tab that wasn't listed yeah okay
that's cool thank
you um just as a followup to that Laura
does tat a have a position
on
um as opposed to TB
venues uh the risk from the TB app which
doesn't involve anybody having to to
leave and and go
anywhere uh not at this stage we're
still um and yeah uh I think there's
certainly harm from online gambling and
using things like a tab app um but it it
is also noted that that's the
responsibility of the DIA and not
necessarily Cel yeah yeah I I guess
that's by way of comment the inequity
that that we have to deal with the only
policy that we can set is around venues
um whereas I think the the app is is
really sorry I don't actually have
the um no I'm quite positive some other
strange ones there but not that um and
and it's kind of unfiltered I mean I
imagine all you've got to do is just say
yeah I'm 18 um and that I I think poses
a real risk as as opposed to what it is
that we're dealing with but we have what
we have and and and that's what we're
here for um look thank you very much for
your comments uh and your submission and
your response to our questions we
appreciate you taking the time thank you
so much thank
you we are running just a oh no we're
almost on time is Jared available
Liz ah Mar Jared good morning um thank
you very much for the submission you've
made on behalf of the gaming machine
Association um we've got 10 minutes
during which um we can hear from you and
answer questions uh ask questions really
the time is yours great thank you I
understand you've got my PowerPoint and
I'll just ask you to flip through the
slides is that right just going
up um so excellent questions for the
last submitter if I could just um assist
of a couple of those um there's a
suggestion that the required 40% for
inago City's not coming back so the the
40% is measured on a GST exclusive basis
which equates to 5.9 million um you got
5.5 million in direct grants so you're
$400,000 short you will find that
$400,000 in the two Club venues that
you've got so the the inago workingman's
club uh the profits from their machines
which remained local of course and
benefited the very members that played
the machines was 370,000
and the extra 30,000 you're missing um
is the profits that come from the club
Southland so you're you're in fact
exactly on the nail on your
40% um the other um very good question
you asked is is there any local data
which suggest that problem gambling has
either gone up or down as a result of
our very different
policies um so the Ministry of Health
requires the treatment providers as part
of their funding to record when someone
Rings or texts or goes Caesar treatment
provider they get asked which
territorial Authority they belong to and
you can look go back and look at how
many people go along so in in Bago city
it's pretty much stayed the same since
2018 so in 2018 we had 100 people from
inago City go to the treatment providers
2019 it was 103 2020 It was 95 21 it was
117 and the most recent dat is 101 so
it's it's it's pretty much said exactly
the same um and that's consistent with
what we've seen nationally when machine
numbers have dropped which I'll go into
a little bit later on machine numbers
have dropped the problem gambling rate
is plateaued so your presentation rates
have plateaued despite the different
policy settings you've
had so in relation to your policy the
first thing I'd like to address is is
your relocation policy um we would like
your relocation policy to be expanded
handed to enable venues that are already
in the CBD or already in the business 2
Zone to be able to relocate within those
zones if they can come to you on a
case-by Case basis and say we're going
to an area that's more desirable from a
harm minimization
perspective in relation to the cap um we
we agree that setting a cap at current
numbers is entirely
reasonable just next slide please so in
relation to relocations relocations are
currently only permitted if the venue is
moving moving into the CBD or the
business 2 Zone um this suggests that if
you're already within that zone you're
not allowed to move uh within within the
zone and of course the reason why we
have relocations is principally a har
minimization tool and venu should be
free to come to council and should be
free to relocate if the new site is more
desirable from a harm minimization
perspective through to the next slide
please so a venue should be venue that's
already in the CBD should be able to
move to another spot in the CBD if it
can show to you that the new location
has a lower deprivation rating um and
the speaker before was correct that
there is a lot of venues that are
already in median to high uh High
deprivation areas let's not entrench
those venues where they are let's give
them the opportunity to move to a lower
deprivation
rating the policy should also allow a
venue that's currently within the CBD or
business 2 Zone that is close to a
suburban area or close to a residential
area or close to a playground or a
church or a moray to be able to move to
a more suitable location away from those
sensitive sites away from the
residential
areas next slide please having the venue
having a relocation policy that enables
you to move within the CBD should also
enable our venues to move to New Modern
refurbished premises if we have a new
modern premise which typically then
changes the focus from more of an
alcohol Focus to more of a food Focus
those venues tend to attract a more
affluent clientele that are less at risk
from suffering from gambling related
harm again if we come to you and say
look we're looking to move within the
CBD it's going to be a smaller premise a
more upm Market premise um a premise
that we consider it's going to be more
appropriate from a har minimization
perspective Council should be able to
consider that on a case-by casee basis
and if they agree um granted if we don't
allow relocation it just entrenches
venues where they currently are which
may be unsuitable
just next slide please in relation to
the cap we entirely agree that adopting
a cap at current numbers is reasonable
we're not advocating for more or
additional machines gaming machines are
naturally declining we've had a 31%
reduction in your local machines since
2015 next through the next slide problem
gambling rate in New Zealand is
extremely low it's only 0.2% of the
adult population and that's all forms of
gambling not simply playing on a gaming
machine uh there is no link between
gaming machine numbers and problem
gambling rates over the last 10 years
we've had 25% of our machines removed
from from our fleets and during that
same 10year period problem gambling rate
has
plateaued through the next slide there
is significant benefits from having the
the local machines first and foremost
it's player entertainment people enjoy
playing our machines gamblings uh uh
popular Pastime Leisure activity 69% of
adult new zealanders participate in at
least one form of gambling at least once
a year next slide please and in as you
heard before in 2022 $5.5 million in
Grants were made locally in addition to
that you've got the funds that come from
your two Club venues which which equate
the extra 40 to 400 to
$450,000 um but there's also grants that
we make honor to National organizations
and Regional organ ations that also
provide an additional benefit and that
tends to be around about 6% of our grant
poll that funding is extremely valuable
and not able to be
replaced um next slide please adopting a
restrictive policy unlikely to reduce
problem gambling but will accelerate the
migration through to online based
gambling next Slide the latest data has
come out has talked about online
gambling and it's showed that a
staggering 20
7% of New Zealand adults have
participate participated in some form of
online gambling with 19% of that group
doing so
weekly you talked about the TB app um
over 80% of the revenue tab's revenue is
through that app on your phone
now um my friend before talked about the
fact that there was a suggestion that
there was no evidence that when all our
venues were closed no one no one
migrated to online which was obviously
you know it's the ultimate test you can
have all the academic research reports
you like but we actually had a situation
where all our venues were closed and the
question was did people go online well
the data is there from all the annual
reports you look at my lotto
2018 the spend was was $200 $200 million
when the venues were closed in 2020 that
jumped up to $430
million next slide please Sky City has
got an online casino an offshore based
online casino based in melta preco $254
million was spent if you have a look at
the annual reports postco that jumped up
to close to $800
million um you can't tell me that when
the physical venues are closed people
aren't migrating the spend shows it
itself you may have recalled probably
about a year ago now kiwi Bank came out
with a a media statement and talked
about how how much money their customers
are spending on their credit cards on
online gambling and kiwi bank's stats
showed that it was $30 million every
month just in their customers being
spent on online
gambling and last slide please offshore
based online gambling is obviously
undesirable there's no local grants no
local employment no funding for the for
the New Zealand government by way of
taxes it's totally unregulated totally
Wild West no harmonization controls no
regulations massive prizes offer off and
when you win um very difficult to
actually receive the priz and there's
frequent adjustments to
gambles thank you and welcome look
forward to your questions thank you g uh
Jared and uh our apologies for
misspelling your name on a couple of our
documents when they went
out um you mentioned the proportion of
people who are using the tab app uh as
being at around
80% is it fair to assume that that high
percentage is a result in the decline in
the number of venues uh that they have
or is it a changing pattern of um ease
of
use I use the TB app um I'm sitting in
front of the TV and and the football's
on and I I say to my son which team's
going to win Ashton and he reckons oh
this team will win and I'd lean over
pick up my phone and 3 seconds later the
bits on I would jump in my car drive 5
minutes down the road stand in a queue
get a ticket printed out and then when I
win repeat that process it's a bit like
saying when you've got Netflix would you
then get up drive to the video store get
a get a tape out bring it home put it
back in the machine and then have to
repeat the process to return it the next
day what is this tape you talk of
[Laughter]
Jared that don't look my tongue was
swimly in my cheek there I'm absolutely
old enough to remember before such
things existed
um TR any
questions no I'm just interested Jared
when you talk about entrenched venues um
where they are what do you mean by that
so having it having gaming machines as
part of a Hospitality business is is a
valuable
commodity it's it's it's not the venue's
primary source of Revenue but when when
you when you've got 40 to 45% of your
Revenue coming from your gaming machine
you're not simply going to pick up your
business and move to a more affluent
part of town and and lose that
opportunity and lose 40 to 45% of the
revenue of your business it just becomes
it's just doesn't make economic sense so
you just entrench those venues where
they are whereas if you give those
operators the opportunity to move and
take their full existing offering to a
more affluent part of town or a more
suitable part of town or to a new modern
refurbished smaller sports bar or or
restaurant type offering then it becomes
entirely economical and you you motivate
those operators to look at those
opportunities and you fac help to
facilitate those moves which are
positive for everyone there's no
downside thank you very much R I do have
one question um point 26 of your
submission talks about the um low
gambling rate by International standards
what I'm interested to to see um and
note I'm not sure if this gets recorded
or not 0.2% of of people age 18 years
and over
um uh in this in this point says that
they have um that's a portion of the age
group is there a particular Surge from
18 to 23 year olds that are um
increasing in there
on um premises gambling um I haven't
seen any data for that from New Zealand
but just two days ago I saw an and some
research in Australia and they were
showing that that younger age group the
16 to 23 year age group um there was a
real acceleration of that in in the
online space particularly in relation to
online casinos and online Sports
Bing okay thank you but it's not it's
not the young people that are turning up
and and finding our machines incredibly
attractive is it more
the it's it's more of a middle-aged
right
okay thank you
thanks Jared the previous submitter
talked about uh figures being below the
required level here you uh added figures
from the club venues which showed that
it came up to the required level during
your submission but if I've got one um
of the local groups of venue operators
saying that they exceed the required
level simple mess is that someone's not
meeting
their so the the the the
40% as a as a as a national require
requirement so every gaming Society
regardless of where their venues are
must meet 40% um there's there's some
some smaller venues that won't actually
make a a 40% profit because they just
don't have the revenue through the
machines and in areas like South Oakland
there's there's machines that have very
high revenue and exceed the 40% um but
we do know how much is spent um and we
do know what the the required
percentages of that which is the
required the 40% on a GST exclusive
basis is 5.9 million your direct grants
are
5.5 the the one of your Club venues is
had a their financial accounts throw
show $370,000 profit you add the other
club into that you are you you will be
at or above the 40% which is what you
would expect okay thank you you've got
you've got excellent local gaming trusts
that are very very focused on returning
funds
locally thank you Jared no further
questions no Jared we appreciate uh the
submission from the gaming machine
machine Association and also your time
this morning thank you very much okay
thank
you
darell hello how are you good we just
give give you a second to come up on
zoom while
we change over there we go oh
goodness thanks for uh your submission
derell as you know um we've got uh 10
minutes for you to make it the is uh
which includes time for questions but um
the slot is yours to use as you please
thank you very much well I'll keep it
succinct um and rather than um
Reinventing the whe and um copying or
going along the same lines as um Jared
there we've um supported um his
submission a couple of times in mind so
I'll just give you a bit of background
about Hospitality New Zealand and then
um read for our submissions and then let
over to you for questions if you have
any so Hospitality New Zealand is a
member-led non-for-profit organization
we represent approximately 3,000
businesses around the country and that
includes cafes restaurants bars
nightclubs commercial accommodation
country hotels and off licenses we've
got 121 year of advocating on behalf of
the hospitality and tourism sector and
we are now led by our new chief
executive Steve Armitage we have a team
of seven regional managers around the
country um and a national office in
Wellington to service our members we
have a board of management which is made
up of elected members and Hospitality
professionals we have 18 local branches
covering the entire country um
representing at a local level all those
member businesses which are located in
the region this obviously is a
submission from the Southland branch of
hospitality New Zealand so thank you
very much for the opportunity to comment
on your classful gambling venues policy
Hospitality New Zealand recommends the
cap option be adopted um and continued
at 226 machine Hospitality New Zealand
supports the gaming gaming machine
Association of New Zealand submission in
particular that evidence and
recommendations for expanding the
relocation provision we agree with GM's
that the relocation provision should be
expanded to include allowing Council to
consider relocations within the CBD or
business 2 Zone already on a caseby Case
basis unlicensed premises are the safest
place to gamble and consume alcohol with
all of their host responsibility and
harm minimization practices that they
follow in adhering to the several
legislation too much restriction for on
premise class 4 operations does push
people online which at present is unable
to be
regulated got a few comments on the code
of conduct Hospitality New Zealand
wholeheartedly supports class 4 harm
minimization demonstrating our
commitments through robust measures
encompassing support advocacy training
and the provision of resources
collaboration is a key principle of our
approach and we actively to seek seek to
engage with venues societies clubs the
clubs the DIA the health promotion
agency and problem gam gambling support
providers to amplify our impact while
Hospitality New Zealand appreciates the
proposed code of conduct and its intent
it is important to not that the majority
of its content are already obligatory
under the gambling act 2003 and the
recently amended gambling harm
prevention and minimization regulations
in
2023 regarding the suggestion of mandat
clocks in gaming rooms we do affirm that
each gaming machine already does display
the time and provides popup messages PS
every 30 to 45 minutes ensuring players
remain cognizant of their gameplay
duration and spending Hospitality New
Zealand also notes that in the case of
addressing intoxicated players as
mentioned on page six and page eight of
the draft policy we emphasize adherence
to the S and supply of alcohol act
2012 specifically section 252 which
creates an offense for the lensey or a
manager of any license premises who
allows an intoxicated person to be or
remain on the licensed premises we
believe that this in itself creates a
strong enough obligation without the
need for additional
Administration thank you very much for
the time to speak thanks Terell um can I
first of all seek
clarification then where hands stands on
the code of conduct
because you've recognized that a lot of
the the points in it exist in
legislation now but I'm I'm not sure I
kind of got the gist of your direction
of support or not support yeah and
that's fair enough I um we we do support
there being um har minimization
practices but I suppose The Stance we're
coming from is a lot of that code of
conduct is already kind of in existence
in the legislation anyway so I do think
it could just be extra work for
yourselves to administer it when it's
already in place in the
legislation even though it's
voluntary the thing is the legislation
isn't voluntary and a lot of what's
mentioned in that code of conduct
majority of it are already um mandatory
obligations under the several
legislations so if I can pricey then you
you you're suggesting that it's
pointless yes that's no that that's fine
if that's your position C can I ask
darell um and and you don't necessarily
have to answer it because it's just a
curiosity question um does the
submission that's come from hands uh
come from your mandate uh from your
membership or or did you canvas uh local
membership yeah canvas local membership
and then I wrote it on their behalf
great thank you that's really useful
yeah you're welcome no questions thank
you Jo no worries where um no you asked
the question I was going to ask I'm good
like that yes still all time benefit of
going first um darell uh once again
thank you for the submission that you've
made on behalf of hospitality New
Zealand we appreciate the fact that
you've gone around your membership taken
the time to submit and given us some of
your time this morning thank you very
much no worries at all and if you did
want to discuss the code of conduct
further and please feel free to reach
out great thank you thank you you're
welcome have a great one see you
bye
K here we go just switching
over well it doesn't say k have we got K
or
Samantha now that Samantha's next um is
K Christensen not here
nope in that case we jump into Samantha
Samantha from Lion Foundation welcome
along thank you very much for giving up
your time we've had a chance to read
through uh your submission we've got um
uh 10 minutes to hear from you which
includes time for questions really the
time is yours and your your your
PowerPoints just gone up thank you so
much um and the PowerPoint really is
just to keep me on track more than
anything else because otherwise I will
continue talking well past my 10 minutes
um look firstly thank you all very much
for the opportunity um to make the both
the written and oral submission and
thank you to your policy advisers for
the work that they have done in putting
this together um essentially the lion
Foundation moving on to the second slide
um sorry I see that I've said it was
established in 1988 it actually wasn't
it was established by trusted in 1985
and since then we have distributed well
over1 billion doar in um Community
grants um with a rounding up to well
rounding down to a $42 million
distribution last year which was
essentially in excess of 43% of of um
the amount that we had available to
distribute um we are a National
Organization um in fact the venue in
Bluff is our last one on the south
island and we operate from that venue
right up until the north of the North
Island um we have we are all inclusive
funer um we prioritize um the areas of
sport uh health education and then arts
and community and culture um we do
prioritize Sports funding but it also
depends on the needs of the community um
we have Regional grants committees who
assist myself the team the trust board
in making sure that funding lands where
it should land um we understand that um
you know the the funding navigate the
funding requirements of all
organizations is an absolute cesspit
it's the only word I can think of it
because we all do things so very very
differently within one set of
legislation um but um yes so our
regional grants committee are local
members so our South iseland committee
distributes money on behalf of well from
all of the funds from all of the tlas
and we pride ourselves on on really
trying to make sure that the funding
lands where it
should um we moving to the next slide
please it's um
we do not support a sinking lid um I'm
not going to sit there and pretend that
well I I'm going to just say we believe
it's a blunt tool which really takes
away a lot of discretion of councils to
really try and make a a balanced policy
with the interests of the gambling act
as well as the interests of the
community at heart um we do absolutely
support uh the retention of a good
relocation Clause um the the harm
minimization attributes of a good
relocation Clause I think are often
under misunderstood or or not um
understood fully is perhaps a better uh
way of summarizing it um we believe the
status quo policy is actually working
really really well um we certainly
haven't had an an inclination to grow
gambling um in in bagle we have a venue
as I say one venue in Bluff which is
licensed to operate nine machines um and
we operate eight in in the pub
um we believe that your current policy
appropriately balances the the eight
purposes of the gambling act it balances
the um the community um access to
funding and it also um with a very
well-funded um
gambling well harm prevention gambling
service provider um we feel that it's
actually a really good Confluence of all
of the aspects um and that is supported
by the the current policy um I I think
that you would have probably read
throughout the submissions both sides of
a very involved and intricate and
interesting coin regarding you know does
a sying lid actually support um a
reduction in problem gambling we would
suggest that there is no evidence to
support that um I have in our submission
gone into extensive
um factors relating to the most well one
of the most recent pieces of work which
was the
malatest um document ation which was
commissioned by the Ministry of Health
um and that in itself significantly
states that the prevalence of problem
gambling um not just pokies and pubs um
isn't reducing um that being said
however um if we move to the next slide
I think one of the the
most let me actually get there um the
the the statistics actually represent
proper gambling across all forms of
gambling um and whilst they are Pockets
yes we do we do accept that the um
operation of um electronic gaming
machines in pubs we do accept that there
is an addictive nature which is why we
have a very strenuous program around our
duty of care and
harmonization um we are very concerned
about the effects of the unregulated
offshore um online it's quite a mouthful
gambling um issues and I I know a lot of
people will say well that's actually not
local council's problems but I think it
is it's all of our problems if we are
closing um venues where um the venue
operators and venue managers are
absolutely committed to a culture of
care and we're essentially forcing
people into the the underworld of of
gambling I don't think that's very
helpful so um having a policy which will
effectively close these physically safe
environments I think needs to be
questioned um based on all the evidence
that we have um finally um the next
slide we do believe that there is an
excellent problem gambling service
available there is masses well a massive
amount of funding which is um allocated
to this over 76 million over three years
and I just want to say I don't know who
is in the room or who isn't in the room
or who you may or may not have heard
from um uh anecdotally uh you know we
obviously keep in touch with our
colleagues throughout the sector and we
believe that there is an incredibly good
service provider in your town in your
District um and we we we think the
numbers especially the the um the data
the data Prevention Services numbers
available on I think it's table 10 on
the ministry website you can be a glass
half full or a glass half empty those
numbers may seem to be High um I choose
to believe that that's because those
numbers excuse me those numbers aren't
High those numbers are actually a good
reflection of the commitment that the
service provider has in your
jurisdiction and the the level of
comfort that people with potential
problems with all forms of gambling have
in approaching people for help and
ultimately that's where we need to be um
if they if anyone does have a problem no
matter what your comorbidity what your
addiction is you you need to feel
comfortable to go to obtain some help um
finally um I just wanted to point out
that our venue operator as well as our
venue manager and all venue staff in our
venue in the bluff they are they all
live work play eat in the area they are
absolutely committed to the culture of
care um they undertake regular training
um and um yeah it's um that is
essentially all I wanted to say to
yourselves today um so my final slide
just says thank you um once again and I
will now attempt to answer questions
good thank you Samantha we'll attempt to
ask
some um thank you for for your
submission on behalf of the lion
foundation and also noting that it's the
eagle and Bluff that uh really is is
your your Venue in our motto um can I
just double check that I I heard your
suggestion correctly and that your
premise in your submission was a sinking
lid potentially reducing the number of
gaming machines available has the
potential of pushing people off into
unregulated online gambling did I hear
that correctly um well yes I think it
does um I absolutely think it does
because ultimately we saw during the co
you know the co pandemic that um online
providers both tab um Lotto um increased
um well the the numbers increased but
most importantly um the the
unfortunately there isn't a lot of of
information available about unregulated
offshore gambling but we know that the
numbers there based on what we have the
numbers are huge um I think there was a
bnz or one of the banks made an article
not so long ago hundreds of millions of
dollars disappearing offsite into on
into unregulated gambling um if you
close a physical spot um let's be honest
people will travel um gambling has been
around forever and will continue to be
around forever um you've got casinos
people will travel to casinos and I'm
not going to go there um but I think the
recent new articles will give us a bit
of a a headliner on that um uh yes I I I
absolutely stand by the fact that um you
know even even malatest in their report
um the lived in
experience uh surveys and questioners
stated categorically um that um yes Theo
word indeed going into un regulated
offline use your Mobile and you can
gamble Smith can also ask with the
proceeds from the eagle in Bluff um uh
what processes are in place by your
grants decision makers to ensure that um
the appropriate amount is returned into
that Community with the grants that you
make um look that is not a a very very
straightforward question I'll try and
answer it as well as I can we receive
applications um we receive applications
and we implore the applicants to please
give us as much information we try and
ask them to draw um as to inform us as
best as they can as to the impact they
will have within the direct Community um
what we do sometimes find however is we
rely on the physical address of the
organization um with with a lot of
people now working from home Etc that
physical address sometimes doesn't
translate to an inle or a Bluff address
it may translate to a queen's Chan
address for example um uh but yet we we
go through the paperwork we'll have
conversations we check websites um we
our our regional grants committee will
often ask us for further information
they themselves check websites so we do
what we can with the information that we
have to ensure that um you know the
local Rowing Club it's building if it
needs a a a roof replace that it
actually does benefit the members we ask
a question in our application form um
designed to give us an indication of
community benefit uh we ask the
applicant themselves to tell us well
within your area of operation what would
you estimate best guess is the benefit
to community so um yes we we we do our
damnedest um but sometimes you know if
if we fund an ambulance for example we
would fund it we would take a little bit
from everywhere because we like to we
like to think that the ambulance isn't
going to stop at an imaginary line
because it was funded from Queenstown or
because it was funded from denan that
it's got to stop at that magical line
and go sorry no money from inic Carle
we're not going there um so yeah it um
it is it's a delicate balance um and we
don't just simply push paperwork around
we do rely we we host for example a
number of webinars where we're saying to
people you know talk to us discuss your
Grant application because we don't like
to Cline things if we can get money to
an organization that's where we want to
go longwinded I know sorry no but a
beauty thanks Samantha Trish any
questions thank you very much Samantha
no h no I think you was
CH there we go you're off scotf free now
Samantha thank you very much for taking
the time to uh to come online and join
us and speak to the submission thank you
very much and my thanks to cat on a
really smooth process thank you very
much well thank you thank
you so I know we were expecting K
Christensen from problemin gambling
Association to zoom in is there
any okay well we're beyond the time that
we had indicated for us so I think we
may continue um before we go into our
process I have a question and I don't
care who answers it from staff
uh whether it's Darren ran or Jillian
but it's around um the the process of
um when when we adopt a policy if there
is a part of the policy that someone is
seeking an exemption from they still do
they have a right to approach us to make
a case for an
exemption yes thank you uh I I know
that's the process through uh liquor
licensing um and I was just wondering if
if if it was the same for um gaming
machines
and uh tab venues so if when we adopt
the policy if somebody believes that
they're able to make a case um that is
an exception to our rules they have a
chance to make that thank you for that
clarification right let's get to the uh
Rec recommendations
um I'm going to go down and move
recommendations 1 to 4 which is that we
receive the report we receive the
submissions note The submitters Who wish
to be heard and note the summary of
submissions I I'll second that thanks
Trish put that all in favor against
carried so that's just procedural I
guess before we get into into
discussions it's worth um
um acknowledging a few
points um firstly the the committee of
councel is completely
independent um and apart from the
submissions that we have received from
various organizations within our
community and and
nationally um we are not beholden to any
of them we are beholden to our great
players who uh either return us or don't
every three
years having been through
each process of review in fact the
initial adoption of the policy and the
reviews since
um the world has shifted marketly and I
think we need to acknowledge that um and
and that's thanks very much to the
online
World particularly these
things um
and that it's
created a very different environment
that
unquestionably adds to the harm which uh
some of our submitters have have
acknowledged this morning and and and I
wholeheartedly acknowledge that in fact
it's moved to the point where not only
is it
offshore gambling apps that are um
completely unregulated
but there are now also apps that um look
like gambling but are not and are simply
for
entertainment and you know that's that's
replica slot machines where you can add
real money from your account to know
chance of a win you are just paying to
to play a game uh and again that's
that's a distraction um and a risk
um and the
same for uh tab venues because the
number of venues that used to exist um
you didn't have to go far
on uh Melbourne cup Tuesday or next week
New Zealand Trot and cup to to go to a
tab and place a
bed apart from all the illegal sweep
staks that people
rant um whereas now you don't even have
to you know leave your office you can
just you can you can do it all on that
socially it's still nice to go to a
venue and and enjoy some uh some
companionship but there are all these
other avenues for
harm uh that exist and the opportunity
to gamble is far greater now than it's
ever
been that said we've only got a small
very small portion of which that we're
able to deal with through an historic
policy
that may or may not be f for purpose but
it is what it is and and we do our best
through that
process the first several versions of
the policy that inago city council
adopted um dealt with a we we had a a
sinking lid policy and it was only the
last time that we went through the
process that we introduced the cap and
that's now probably the uh the biggest
point that we' we've got to consider
um are we recommending to the well-being
committee uh that we adopt either a
syncing lid or cap for um for tib
venues
um and for the number of um
machines
I'm curious as to where the rest of the
committee sit just as an overview before
we go through
that anyone want to kick off I will
thanks Trish um based on what I read and
um the submissions I've heard have
clarified that today to me I think it's
got to be
kept can I ask why just um well the two
things that I think is that is it's the
fact um let me just get my my thinking
here together time just you to ask me
that
question that's why I said t i did lob a
little bit of grenade I do you think now
I think that the this Merit and having
the place where the people we can have
the same venues we do not want to
encourage people to stay at home and go
online online we can't stop that but if
we have the places where they are people
are used to they go for the social um
environment as much as well possibly but
for for the gambling and that's why I'm
leaning towards it okay cool thank you
and look sorry I didn't mean to to drop
that
on it's not often that Council goes
through the process of considering a
policy and and open and I'm just really
wanting to be transparent recognizing
the fact that you know people have put a
lot of thought into this submissions and
there are some powerful points both ways
so Ria T you're it I'm thanks um having
heard from um various members from the
um engagement H that the council
undertook um and having a good a into um
that discussion in those groups there
then coming through and looking at what
our absolute um evidence provided to us
through our
submitters um and having the words use
that uh a sinking lid as a blunt Tool uh
that we need to be aware of that it
could um outlay a different behavior um
into our community that is concerning um
I'm of the mindset that I would support
a cap over a sinking lid um my other
mindfulness is also about the um the
venues the class for venue policy so I'm
trying to weigh the upper my head at the
same time um I think we've had a good
argument from our submitters um as to
the different
um um CBD and um business zones and what
they've asked for throughout the
submission so I think that the
information that we've been provided
with um it's quite clear it's very
informative and that's why I'm leading
to where I am okay thanks R uh for
transparency where does Darren said good
question in the middle in the middle
between two roses so I was told
earlier
um so having been through this process a
few times and
and watching the results
of uh a sinking lid
and the potential effects that it's had
as there have been movement
and and closures um we were I look
there's a sneaking suspicion I think we
were up around the 300 mark way back
when we when we started um and now we've
got 226 in in my mind I think a cap has
worked in in the
past term and that we haven't
had and and in saying that I think we
need to acknowledge that it's been a
strange period as well because we've had
had a lockdown through it um
um
uh I am mindful of
the
increased um poverty and deprivation
that our communities face and
particularly as Tatu order pointed out
in Mal and Pacifica um
communities
um but much like
the
alcohol uh
laws
um I think the the risks from alcohol
consumption are highest from those who
are drinking at
home um because they're not
supervised um and I think the same
applies uh for gambling uh and that I
watched and sat it uh machines where the
reminders come up and by satday it's a
very occasional thing but I do
um I have
seen staff within those venues approach
people who have obviously been sitting
there um but I'm also aware of the the
um items in the news around uh an Orland
casino that may not have been executing
its UH responsibilities properly uh and
and that'll be dealt with in the same
way
that it was I suspect with the denan
casino when it failed to to meet its
obligations I don't hear feedback from
within our community that that is a
problem um and you know people at the
moment are quick to uh point out when
they're not they're not happy with
things so from that
perspective I am comfortable with where
you're both at in in looking at caps uh
as a as opposed
to um sinking lids with the comfort that
um this policy comes up for review
regularly
Brianna um just an administrative matter
before you vote on resolution five um
just to say writing another report could
we amend resolution 5 to recommend that
the community well-being committee
recommend to council to adopt yes
yeah because the final decision will
rest with
Council and and noting that um if
because I know that there was some
discussion around the document that we
were going to take out for consultation
around caps and sinking leads um that
whichever recommendation we go with
Council
either uh approves a recommendation or
rejects it they do not get to negotiate
on it because council did not go through
this this hearings process if they
reject it we start again and we go back
out for consultation uh and we can go
around and around around that malberry
bush until people understand how the
process works um that's that's fine yeah
um if if that is council's pleasure then
then so be
it so let's move to uh recommendation
five
the recommendation is that a cap board
venue policy and class for venues policy
is what you're wanting to put
forward who's moving that I
Trish second thank you that all in favor
I I against
carried are there any points of
contention within recommendation
six that the committee wishes to flash
out because the relocation formed part
of that or are you comfortable with
having heard and read the
submissions with those
recommendations I'm comfortable with it
where in my head when I was listening to
the submitters talking about the
relocation provisions
and for those reasons being the harm
prevention and minimalization um a more
extensive nicer venue and what have you
I felt more comfortable with that cuz
prior to that I wasn't sure exactly how
that
um could be of a
non-benefit so I had to get my head
around what that what that submission
part of that submission was alluding to
and then with the fact I do beg the
pardon and say this if a venue wants to
relocate and um someone seeks an
exemption yes they can so I feel
question was yeah so I feel satisfied
with that buffer there um that gives me
more confidence good that's why I asked
it um just to to a matter of process
that I knew existed there I wasn't 100%
sure was really good never had an
application for an exemption under this
process but it it does uh does exist so
with that in mind uh who wishes to move
the adoption of item six as it stands or
is somebody wanting to move it with any
variations I'm happy to move it as it
stands and no second
okay there any further matters you wish
to discuss around
that if not I will put that all in favor
I
against
carried Council as that brings this
process to its
um conclusion as as we just pointed out
we now U make a recommendation to the
community well-being committee which
then recommends onto Council again
Community well-being committee can
either um AC approve the recommendation
or reject it uh so there's two further
bites that that happen but ultimately if
it doesn't go through we go back and and
start again and that's fine uh to the
people who've uh submitted um whether
they were end ended up online not or or
here in person thank you for that and
for those who uh had only um offered
written submissions those have been uh
considered and hold equal weight whether
people wished to speak to them or not so
thank you very much for that well that
in mind uh I'll close this hearing thank
you very much and thank you for your
attendance thank
you